ho ho Merry Christmas feed the starving  children  come on you [ __ ] [ __ ] we got a  job I'm talking millions this time why  are you even out of the joint anyway you  know they used to sterilize guys like  you keep the world from becoming some  Negro Land of Oz early release you races  [ __ ] [ __ ]  I'm 21 officially a man as creepy you  still gonna pop my cherry what [ __ ] no I  said I'd get it done by somebody else  come on baby come on get a bite of this  pumpernickel buried  I want minecraft halo 5 guardians  Assassin's Creed chronicles trilogy was  great that's great I don't know I have  no idea what that [ __ ] is you could be  speaking [ __ ] swine you ain't no one  knowing that her grand theft auto fine  no I don't care  you look like one of those trolls that  gamespot Willy Wonka you got a gigantic  titties Thanks  I get to wear this your ass Anton out  there man associate out dogs got this  thing all lined up [ __ ] stick Bob you  still hit like your [ __ ] father